hey everyone thanks for coming to PED in
New York
2023 and thanks for coming to this
afternoon session without any further
Ado I'll let our our guest speaker take
over wo thank you um can hear everyone
hear me okay oh all right awesome so hi
everyone my name is nian Aran uh I am a
New Yorker so there we go and my I'm a
senior Cloud Advocate on the AI advocacy
team at Microsoft and today I want to
talk to you about simplifying data
analysis with GitHub code spaces you
notebooks and open AI but there's a qust
I actually want to talk about a very
particular audience so how can I start
so it turns out that not all of us are
python experts not all of us are python
data scientists it takes quite a few
years for you to get really really
expert in that so I have this happened
to me many times including in my life
I'm an app developer I'm not a python
expert I'm not a data science expert but
I keep encountering needs for python
tools and techniques and Technologies in
the work I do how can I learn enough to
use it to tackle those problems so here
a few examples and they kind of like
reflect three roles in my life first one
I have a very precocious 15-year-old who
wants to do competitive programming did
you all know that the USA Computing
Olympiad now allows python as one of the
languages you can code in but guess what
C and C++ and Java are the ones that are
competitive so there's tons of solutions
for it not that much for python he loves
python but he can't find any resources
to actually skill up how can I solve
this problem the second one as a web
developer I do a lot of accessibility
compliance testing there's a tool we
built called play ride that if you run a
test on a website against an
accessibility Checker it'll give you a
test report here's the kicker how many
of you knew that the average page has a
thousand plus elements how many of you
knew that there are 100 rules you have
to evaluate for those thousand elements
how many of you knew that every rule has
what three to five checks that's a lot
of data points and I need use this to
tell the developer hey that's the thing
you should be fixing because that's
where the error is we need a way to give
them that Insight at in the in their uh
editor and last but not least we all do
this we go hit apis we get a ton of data
and we want to like deliver this to the
user in a way that they understand want
to visualize it so how do we do it so
with this in mind I had actually two
objectives and I really really love the
fact that the keynot speaker set me up
so nicely for this today objective one
is focus learning I'm not an expert but
I want to use it and I don't have the 10
years of experience that many of you do
so I want to prioritize what I need to
learn to get my job done to get me
closer to the goal so I don't want to
boil the ocean just tell me what I need
so I can optimize my time the second
thing and this is important is I want
transferable learning whatever I do I
want to make it easy for others to take
what I built and reproduce it or extend
my work so that I can actually do what I
know and then maybe give a data
scientist and say can you look at it now
right so what tools and environment
should I be using to make this
possible here is my Challenge and I
think we've all faced this first is a
development environment setup can be
really hard to navigate for a beginner
and I've experienced this right here
right we walk into a room we're like hey
there's a tutorial oh I'm on a Mac you
need to install this oh well and you
know how many of you heard the term it
works on my
machine yeah that's the one that kills
me every time yeah I know it works on
your machine so this happens to me
because my son works on Windows I work
on my I'm like it's working for me and
he's like it's not working for me so
first one develop an environment I want
to be productive how do I get really
quickly to where I can start working
second is the learning process the
problem when you don't know something is
you go to Google or you go to stack
Overflow 3 hours later you realize you
were finding out stuff you didn't want
to know and you forgot where you started
right so I want a way to learn that
doesn't disrupt my focus on the task
that I'm doing so how do I get that that
done and last but not least and this is
the most subtle but hardest problem
there are knowledge gaps that hamper my
intuition because I don't have that
level of experience and it's kind of
like that thing I don't even know what I
don't know right it would if it would be
great if I knew what I didn't know so I
can ask someone but I don't even know
what I don't know so what if I miss
something so what I want to cover today
is how I went about my adventure solving
this problem first transferable learning
everyone I met says use you notebooks
it's easy you can document what you're
doing people can look at it they can
understand it great for a consistent de
development environment I want to talk
about gith up codes spaces how many of
you here have heard about code spaces
just a quick show of hands oh nice I
have some friends in the room third is
focus learning in context I want to use
GitHub co-pilot and I want to talk a
little bit about why that's useful and
last but not least I want to talk a
little bit about something that came out
of Microsoft research called leader and
that's how I kind of say hey there's
another tool that can help me build that
intuition that I l so what do you need
if you want to follow along uh given the
time I may not be able to do as much
live but all the code is in there there
is my slides are in there as well so
grab it what you're going to need is
you're going to need a GitHub account if
you want to follow along uh you need to
use GitHub code spaces there is a free
quoda so don't worry about it a candle
data set is what I'm using but you can
feel free to bring your own there's a
free trial of GitHub co-pilot but it is
a paid thing otherwise so if you don't
want to use it the last two things you
know that's okay but uh if if you have
those and you want to try them out feel
free so I'll keep putting this up at the
end again but that's a repo that you can
kind of get all the stuff and if you
have questions just leave me an issue
there and I'll answer it after the fact
so let's get started first my very first
problem that I want to solve is how do I
get a reproducible
environment that I can work with without
spending a lot of time setup and that is
GitHub Cod spaces with jupyter notebooks
so how many of you knew that GitHub
actually has a Cod spaces Jupiter
template that you can just grab and
instantiate so if you go to this repo
I've actually started from that seed
template and all I all I need you to do
is go Fork that
repo and then if you drop down in your
fork if you drop down that code you'll
see a thing which says create code space
on name we're going to be very bold and
try to create a second code space I
already have one running but here's mine
so I'm just going to go ahead and say
hey let me go and create another code
space
so what's happening here is that you'll
see it's setting up for me an
environment in the cloud and that's
it I have it so this thing I have a
whole bunch of examples in here but
let's take the default this is the
default that comes with that code space
template so I want to be able to run
this it's detecting kernels it says Hey
select a curl that you want and I'm like
there's a python environment oh it
already pick it so I picked that oh R
away there you see it selected python
P10 now I go ahead and say great let me
close all these so you can see
this right now I can just say run all
and if I'm the gods are good and our
Wi-Fi is good my Jupiter notebook is
running hey I got my environment I got a
notebook running I don't know any of
this stuff but it just worked this means
that when I go to a workshop next time I
don't need to tell you all please go
install this run this I like just go to
this thing Fork it we're done right so
this is the first thing I wanted to talk
about which is um you know code spaces
gets you started really quickly so the
next exercise is you see this Visual
Studio code ID right there we did that
right now and we ran the default
notebook right it comes with a python
kernel that you can use no harm done we
ran the example we saw this and we were
set up what happened what was happening
under the covers this is gith up code
spaces so how does gith up Cod spaces
work if you look at it on the right in
the gray box you see Azure and inside
Azure you see a blue virtual machine and
inside the blue virtual machine you see
a container I want you to focus on the
green container that's called a
development container what it is it's
just a darker container but why is it
interesting in the case of GitHub code
spaces when you start it up GitHub is
basically taking a container based on
some configuration file which we look at
in just a second running it in a VM in
the Azure Club you now literally have a
machine that's set up exactly the way
you want it and it does one thing more
it sets it up so that your editor can
connect to it in the cloud out of the
box so now the minute I clicked it I
have vs code running in my browser
connecting to a container in the cloud
and I didn't have to do
anything but wait it gets better maybe
I'm not a vs code fan turns out if you
go into your edital preferences you can
pick Visual Studio code you can pick jet
rins you can pick jupyter lab but I'm
going to tell you to stick with this
code extent because there are some cool
things we can do with it we'll look at
that in a second but I want to just
briefly talk about two things here we're
looking at this container in GitHub Cod
spaces and you're probably
wondering there's no free lunches right
yeah you're right there so code spaces
just like everything else if you exceed
the free quarter will have a cost but
the free quter is fairly generous what
you'll be paying for is using storage
and using uh CPU time so as long as you
stop your code space when you're done
you can save your quote and it's fairly
generous but let's say you do want to
like do something locally we're going to
talk about that by first understanding
how the development container works so
under the cover it's just a um a Docker
container as I'm showing here that can
be connected to and if you see that the
the key the word that you're looking for
is configuration as code what it is is
it's got a single Dev container. Json
file let's see if we can look at
it so over here you'll see that there's
a Dev container. Json can you see this
okay yeah so you'll see that it says
there is a standard image now this is a
bit of a heavyweight image but this is
the one that comes with the default
later on you can customize to pick the
one that's configured for you but the
nice thing about this one this is the
universal container image that has
python it has node it has cond it has
everything and the kitchen sink so you
can pretty much do anything you want and
you can see that underneath it's kind of
setting it up with saying hey once You'
install this image please run all the
dependencies that have given in
requirements. text and then do whatever
else I need before I tell the user that
it's ready to go so you can actually
extend it so this death container. Json
is configuration as code why does it
matter it means I can Version Control my
environment if I decide tomorrow I want
to add a new extension I can check that
into GitHub and then I have the same
environment available to everyone the
very next day second is the life cycle
hooks means that I can can keep
customizing it after the image is built
and do whatever I want but last but not
least when you see this image there's
nothing about a BM in the cloud that
means I can actually connect to this
container I can deploy the container
anywhere that containers can be deployed
including in my local device so if I
want to run the same thing locally I
simply clone my report to my local
device start a Docker desktop open it in
container and if you don't believe me
here it is this is my Docker desktop
there is the image that I'm running and
I'm running the exact same code here
except you can see here it tells me this
is a depth container on desktop Linux
and over here in the other one it'll
tell me that it's on code spaces sugar C
SC oh my God all right I'm don't blame
me for the names um the bottom line
though is that this allows us to have an
environment that works locally in the
cloud and it's completely set up for me
with no additional thing but wait
there's more someone once told me hey
the problem with all the development we
do is it's not going to translate to
production well it will if you use the
same container image that you deploy in
production as the basis for the
container that you use in development so
over here you can see that between the
production and DEP containers we have an
inner loop and outer loop and the
production they have the same runtime
it's just that the development container
has additional tools and debugging
things that help me in development but
they get stripped out in production but
what this means is that I can debug and
test this knowing fully that if it run
in this environment it's going to run
reasonably well in
production so fix two of my problems I
got a notebook and it's running in get
code spaces and it didn't take me any
time at all now I'm on to challenge
number two how do I get Focus learning
so this is where I'm going to talk about
GitHub co-pilot so how many of you have
used GitHub co-pilot ah yes my people
how many of you VI get have co-pilot
chat same okay fewer because today I
heard someone say there is no chat
interface I'm like no no there's a chat
interface that is a very important chat
interface okay so now I'm telling you
why when I said hey use a an IDE having
vs code is good because you can install
vs code extensions and add them into
your depth container. Json and now
everybody who's using it gets the exact
same environment with the latest and
greatest tools I'm going to tell you
about two of them for now let's talk
about get up co-pilot adding it in yes
there's a 30-day trial and you have to
subscribe to it later but let's say
you're you're all like you know checking
it out all right you just literally
right click select it and say add it to
my Dev container and you're done what
it'll do is it'll add it to Def
container in the customization section
where it says vs code extensions it will
rebuild the container now you've got it
activated we can try that out I think
it's already done though but um well
I'll show you what that looks like so if
you were to do it you'll see that that
little chat icon shows up here and over
here you'll see it right there so this
is vs code's co-pilot chat extension
what chat does is it gives you two
modalities for engaging with GitHub
co-pilot you can chat here in a window
or you can go into this code and just do
command I and it'll give you an inline
chat interface that will work right in
context of the file you're
on this is important to me and you'll
see why in a minute did I tell you I had
a 15year old that I I like I actually
want to earn his respect more than I
want to earn yours cuz it's harder so I
need it to look cool right so here we go
I want to say what can I do with
co-pilot chat that helps him under the
hood what is co-pilot chat it's a
generative AI model that was developed
by open AI with GitHub and Microsoft and
it's been tuned beyond the original
model as recently as in July it can give
you code explanations it can give you
code assistance it's a code generation
tool primarily but it can do other
things code refinement unit testing
codee profiling you name it
but the proof of the pudding is in the
eating right we're talking notebooks can
generate a notebook for me so I said let
me impress my son so this us ACO has
these really tough problems I should
have kept it open but let's see I bet
even you couldn't do it because these
kids are too smart so these are usaco
problems if you think of lead code think
of this as lead code for high school
students so the thing is that you have
all these problems he's starting at the
bronze level so I'm looking at it and I
will show you this should make us all
really really
embarrassed um I'm set up for python so
you see that that's that's all he has
that's all the examples he has if I go
in here and I change it to C++ oh this
is C++ I should check in Python because
I said these to be easy so look at how
many this is right it's showing me one
step further this is actually C++ the
other one was python it's taking time
all right uh long St short though come
on
man this Bond on me you you're you're
you're doing this to me so terribly you
can go check it out on your own um all
right so let's just keep this for now
and say I want to look at solve problems
and I want to look at something which is
this rectangle geometry all know
rectangle
geometry okay neither did I so here is a
block billboard problem if you think
that this is easy the block billboard
problem looks like this it's a natural
language problem about a cow and two
Billboards and a
truck so we have to solve this thing so
I said set me up a notebook this is how
easy it is and I'm going to work through
this in here you can try it out yourself
but I can go to get a co-pilot chat and
basically said I'm not going to do it
again because I already did it once but
I can basically say can you create me a
new notebook and let's say over here I
say uh for now I want to actually let's
say I want to learn about geometry right
so say you teach me about rectangle
geometry can you all see it okay
okay
in Python right so here I am I want to
impress this kid I'm a JavaScript person
I'm like I can teach you how to do
rectangle geometry in Python it actually
writes the curriculum for me it creates
a notebook for me it puts the content in
and gives me some sample test right so
it says okay create it not sure if it's
correct or not but if you wait here at
the bottom you'll see it starts defining
it for me right now at the very least
it's giving me a starting point so I'm
not too mad I'm going to let it continue
if you keep looking at it it'll start
building this out but I have a lot to
cover so I'm going to go back and say
okay it's not perfect but we have a
start now I'm going to set up the
notebook with that problem the specific
problem yes here has a rectangle
geometry problem it's a nasty one
there's a solution that's been published
and I want to help him understand this
right so I've copied this over and if
you're following along you can actually
see it right in here so if you go into
so you see this is actually completed
the whole thing and given me all of the
stuff if I run it hopefully all of them
run but if not we'll have to go back and
and fix it and that's also a great thing
cuz can ask profile to go fix it so you
can see here aha so we already see that
it's doing this issue where it's putting
in these markdown markers in a python
cell but if I do that it does work okay
so we've got to fix a few things it's
not perfect but it does help us get
somewhere fast and in here in the
notebooks I actually have under Pi data
that very first notebook that I created
for the demo that I was talking about
his entire thing is sitting in here
right so you can see that the solution
that they gave us is a slow solution and
what I really want do is have my son
learn I don't want him to copy I want
him to learn so I'm like okay says what
is time complexity like go ask so we go
ask copile what is time complexity and
it explains this to us but I want to
actually go the next step and say hey
you have a solution someone wrote why
don't you ask you to explain that you so
figure out how it was how it went from
the language problem to a solution we
can do that but now look at the little
things it does right in line it says I'm
explaining this to you but do you want
to know this other thing that's related
to this and you can click then keep
going so yes it's still going down the
rabbit hole but I'm not leaving my
editor and it's contextualized to the
task I'm actually on which is useful now
I'm like how can I improve the solution
because obviously this is not the right
time complexity and it says yeah your
time complexity is bad I can give you a
solution that give you better time
complexity and it does but we noticed
that the solution that was given to us
by USA you use classes so we both can go
back and say can you simplify this by
using a class and it does why am I
telling you this this means that I can
give this my my kid this thing and say
figure it out but go step by step and
understand what's happening but wait we
can do more this is a billboard problem
at the end of it I want them to get an
intuition for what that problem is right
so I'm like okay hey can you visualize
these Billboards on the top that's all I
said and I said sure I can I'm going to
use math PL liit here it is and that
those are the two Billboards and the
truck in between now we can actually
connect what we read to a problem to
solve it so this is the power of like
how do I stay in line and in focus with
GitHub co-pilot hopefully that makes
sense I'm trying to keep an eye on the
time okay um the third part now I'll
come to my problem enough of that data
visualization the traditional way
remember I'm a JavaScript developer with
a lot of data I don't know what the
libraries are I don't know what I'm
looking for I ask the questions I know
about but it would be great if I could
get some help so here's what we're going
to do Gra data set I'm sorry you all can
do the European premier league but I'm
going to go with the Indian Premier
League which is Cricket so this left
side is a CLE data set for Cricket the
right side for those of you who don't
know Cricket is a 10 partx one we're
going to go through the cricket data set
cuz that's what we're going to do but my
point is you can bring your own data set
that's okay the real thing is I have a
data set that I don't know anything
about and I want to explore it so I want
to see do these tools help me so first
can I actually get it to teach me how to
visualize this I asked my python friend
and they say go you CBO I'm like where
do I start so I go to it and say create
a notebook that tells me how to use the
cbor package and can you use this data
set to show me how that's done and lo
and behold it does what it did before
right so if you go into the code you'll
actually see this right here so it does
this thing where it says okay I'm going
to kind of build this way and it'll run
and actually give me some of this data
right it gives me various things now
what do I get out of this I get two
things is this the perfect visualization
a data science person would be rolling
on the floor right now saying this is
not what you
want but I don't have 10 years in 5
seconds or 5 minutes I've got something
more than I knew before now I can refine
it now I know where to start right but
at least I'm beginning to say oh I need
to understand how these two relate I
need to understand how this is done Etc
so it gives me it opens my mind to oh
here are the things I want to learn so
so yes it taught me to visualize it it
wrote the whole thing for me now I just
have a starting point and I refine
it can I have it fix mistakes cuz this
was a strange thing for me this is
co-pilot but it seemed to understand
Cricket because it tried to visualize
things on runs I'm like wow okay but it
turned out the data set didn't actually
have any column called runs so when I
actually ran it it said oh it doesn't
work so it was hallucinating that there
was a column called runs but there was a
column called high scores so I just go
in and say can you fix this and use high
score for runs and it does and now I
have the distribution for high scores
right so my point is that it gives me a
starting point I can refine it I can ask
it when I'm stuck and I get further and
further towards my goal it's not perfect
but for me this is better than
bad but wait I can do
more I mean I have to say this all right
uh I can now ask you to visualize things
that I want right and I can say can you
visualize the distribution of the high
score based on venue cuz I'm from chenai
I'm like they really are the best but
they're not okay enough said the people
who laugh we know who they are okay so
the point of it though is that I can now
ask it and I get two things one is yes I
get a visualization but more importantly
I start learning oh here's how I use
seor for this kind of thing I need to
use a box plot this is how it put it and
that's important to me because it's a
learning
process so I'm there right you think I'm
done who thinks I'm
done all right how many of you think
that if you were given you're data
scientist and you were given the data
set you'd be happy with that graph and
give it to your boss and ask for a raise
anybody yeah I thought not so the bottom
line is I'm still stuck on problem
number four I don't know what I don't
know I don't know if this is what I
should be visualizing there must be
something better how do I learn how do I
get that intuition without that 10 years
experience
and this is where open AI comes in and I
want to talk a little bit about
Microsoft leader so what is Microsoft
leader Microsoft leader is a open source
project from the Microsoft research team
that I learned about recently you can go
to ak. msle GitHub if you want to go
look at the actual uh package and read
the paper or you can go to ak.
ms.org that's a kind of like an
organization we set up to allow people
to come in and try to build stuff on it
so we have a codes spaces template vor's
actually made a streamlet app we just
want the community to come in and play
around right but first I have to
convince you that you need to go play
around so what is leader leader is a
library for generating data
visualizations and data faithful
infographics it's grammar agnostic so it
to work with any programming language
but of course want python uh and it has
a bunch of libraries but that it's
configured with by default but it is
open source so I can go in and actually
set it up to use something else that I
want as well it also works with multiple
large language providers although I have
configured it now to use open AI the
original uh repo has all the
instructions to try various things what
does it do first one is a summarizer
it's basically setting me up with here
is I'm going to take your data file I'm
going to give you a representation that
tells me what it has that becomes the
foundation on which it does everything
else the goal Explorer is literally
going to tell me what things I could
find out in the data the generator is
then going to help me visualize it and
the infograph which I was not able to
run because it needs a GPU so if any of
you have gpus handy please try it out
would actually help you build
infographics but it helps to go look at
what that does right so first thing and
this is where I want to go back to one
other benefit of code spaces first thing
is to run this you need an open API key
open AI API
key how many of you love setting this at
command line with an environment
variable cuz you just memorized your
open AI key and you just carry around
with you how
many yeah right I want you to memorize
numbers for me please so the bottom line
is we have a big problem with these keys
right because we have these notebooks so
people say just fill it in in there and
now you check that in and your keys
leaked can do that so we need to have
the keys available to these environments
without them being exposed you can do it
with a regular thing where when I'm
running it in my local container I have
this environment copy I make a copy put
the variable in and then I use n to load
it up great jhub code spaces will take
give you one additional benefit go to
settings go to code spaces and you
secret set it up you will never see it
again you'll never be able to see that
key again it will always be there but
now you can go and attach it to as many
repositories as you want you just
literally say oh it's a secret it every
time someone opens a Cod space please
associate sorry every time I open a Cod
space because I don't want other people
using my key so the nice thing about
this is now I can do demos and even if I
showed you my code spaces and I can
because I'm so uh great I'm so confident
and you know
this will be the death of me because for
all you know this is the day they decide
well we're going to show it all to you
um if you go into settings. uh get codes
spaces you'll see right here I have an
open API key right I'm bra going to open
it because you'll see I'm attaching to
all these report but you'll never see
the value again right so it's good now I
have the set up so I can use it so let's
go see what that does for
me at this point I can data summarize so
here
I just this is on the left side I can
look at the CSV file as a table in
GitHub because GitHub will do it for me
on the right side all I did is leader
here is my CSV file tell me more right
all I've got is I'm using an open a
model configure it generate it for me
summarize it here is the summarization
object which tells me here is what I've
decided is the representation of your
data oh sorry now I can ask you to
generate goals for me over here I say
generate 10 goals with a default Persona
I have no idea who the default Persona
is say generate 10 goals tell me 10
things I can get out of this data and
that's great for me because even if I
don't do them all I'm able to at least
get an intuition for oh I can do all
these things and it gives me the
question it gives me visualization and
rational it says okay you can ask this
question here is how it would get
visualized and this is why this
visualization is useful for that right
which is
great but I can actually do more I can
add a Persona so I can say hey I want
you to reply to the with a Persona of a
person who loves Mumbai all right okay
uh Mumbai is one of the teams they
always win they got lots of money they
are the Yankees of the Indian cricket
World
okay I'm the wrong crowd this is New
York okay so the Go Generation with
personas when I put this Persona and
said hey the Persona is a fan of the
move I you'll see that now the goals
have changed over to start focusing on
questions related to the data that's
related to that team which is amazing
for me and now I can say Okay based on
that help me visualize stuff so on the
first side I'm just saying visualize a
goal for me you pick whatever you want
to visualize visualize it pick whatever
you think is best it does that on the
right side I'm like you know what I
actually want to change the parameters
and this is where I want you to think
about why I want to use this versus
co-pilot because co-pilot could also do
this for me you saw it I could say do
some visualization but I don't know how
that works under the covers it's a I'm
giving a prompt I have no idea what the
model is I can't tune it here I'm using
an API that goes to that model that I
have parameters I can tune so I can say
please please change this and use this
temperature go ahead and use this model
please can you use this library and that
means I'm able to control the
visualization a little better is this
making sense so far yes okay so great
but we can also do user query so over
there we basically said hey leader go
ahead I'm just telling you to use your
default methods do whatever you can for
me over here I'm actually saying give me
the specific thing and it can do that
but like I said the better thing about
this is I can actually parameters I can
go the extra mile and say please use
this color please use this Library
increase this height so it looks pretty
God knows what else do I want so the
fact is I can and the best thing about
it is you look under the covers it is
open source you can go in and also tune
the apis to have other things that you
want added in last couple more quick
examples data visualization explanation
over here you can ask you to explain why
that visualization is and it takes three
different things accessibility which is
the physical appearance like why did I
think this color is it accessible
contrast rati Etc transformation was
there a transformation involved why did
I put the visualization but I really
want you focus on the right side where
I've put the location of the file that
defines the system prompt that generated
this in other words you could go in and
change that to have other things that
you want added in here's how you would
now visualize this and recommend it for
a
goal and that's pretty much that was my
like round trip tour of all the stuff
that we could have done we basically
started with four goals and want to see
if we met them but where do we go from
here I'm going to tell you one last
thing this a literally added last night
because the VOD team keeps putting stuff
out there there is this extension called
Data Wrangler how many of you used
it okay you don't
count so this they told me about it and
I was like damn so data Wrangler is a vs
code extension that if you install it
what it does is when you have a data
frame with a head you call head on that
it'll actually give you a button that
says launch data rangler and it launches
this view where you can go in and fix
things and it writes the pandas code for
you you're doing it through a visual
interface but it writes it for you so on
the right side you can see that for the
data I didn't have to do anything I get
insights the data grid code preview
summary panel operation panel operation
history if you want to try it out on the
data that I have I'll be checking in the
extension today I have it in my local
version so you'll see it but you can try
it out literally install the extension
in Dev container you'll see now that for
that same IPL set I get this little
launch data Wrangler button click it and
I get this View and it shows me the
visualizations it tells me how much data
I have it tells me what I'm missing I'm
able to look at it and go I need to
clean this up I need better
representation I need to do something
else and again this kind of reinforces
my thing that I didn't know python but I
can get productive really fast because I
have better
tooling okay and I think I'm kind of at
the end I'm just going to leave you with
a couple of links for those of you are
interested if you look at this last part
of this right open AI one of the things
we're recognizing in the generative AI
space is that we can do a lot but half
of it requires us to understand how to
engineer these prompts so a whole bunch
of us at Microsoft just released this
it's an open source course if you want
to think what are there 12 lessons all
in Jupiter notebooks all in code spaces
so definitely check it out it just
launched a day ago and it's already hit
1K stars and it's trending so I guess
people like it we'd love for you to try
it out and give us comments tell us what
we should be doing differently but more
importantly look at it because it kind
of goes from the basics of generative AI
but also has applications here chat here
loow code app and so on uh two more on
the left side if you're interested in
this topic the the repo that I sent you
was just the the the kind of workshop
for today but I'm actually maintaining
this report a whole bunch of resources
there's a panda AI coming out I have no
idea anyone used it it's on my
radar so there's a whole bunch of
resources I'm going to be kind of
stacking that repo up with more and more
examples and write stuff about it so if
you're interested watch the repo like it
if you think it's useful on the right
side that is the leader project and the
leader or if you're interested in that
work uh check that out definitely go
look for the streamlet app that uh um
Victor built and there's a Code spaces
template that you can start from which
has no data you just put yours in there
launch it and you'll be good to
go so hopefully I did my job will you
all agree that I covered these four
things yes yes yes yes no so awesome
thank you I I thought I wouldn't make it
in time but I started with a very simple
thing I'm not a python expert but I need
to know python in my job I'm an app
developer how do I get productive
without having the 20 years of
experience many of you do so I want
transferable learning with jupyter
notebooks got it on a consistent Dev
environment with code spaces got it on
focused learning with co-pilot got it
and for intuition there are libraries
like Lita there are probably more out
there but I can use them and my big
takeaway message is that in this
generation of AI python is king or I
should say queen you got to always go
with the right thing right all right and
that means that we need to make it easy
for people who don't know python to come
in and join us and py is one of the
friendliest communities I know so here
are some ways in which we can make it
easier for them to get started using the
stuff that's built here uh that's all I
had for you I think I hopefully I'm on
time I have a few minutes left I think
right you're good I am awesome so thank
you very much you can go check this out
if you have any questions uh or comments
let me know also absolutely would love
it if you looked at it and said this is
not what you should have done I can give
you a better example please do uh if you
want to bash any one example do it for
the competitive one because then I can
make the 15year old fix it which would
give me all kinds of Joy uh for what
it's worth this is not his repo he has a
whole other or but I refuse to let that
be put on here but I do think that this
is a great space for us to get the Next
Generation to get excited about these
things so I would love love love to get
any kind of insights from you and with
that thank you all so much for giving me
your time this afternoon um I'll be
hanging around here if anyone has
questions now ask away but otherwise
yeah I'll be hanging out here so just
come talk to me uh thanks so
much oh yeah go for
it yeah I don't know if this works but
we can
try can you try
this I was just wondering where
the where the docker image for that Dev
environment is and what the licensing is
for that oh he you are so my pal oh my
God thank you a
licensing I'm like you know I forgot to
say some things but people come along
and so two things there is something
called there's a dock registry where you
can get it from but I will also talk
about two things there are two uh okay
here so the one that I showed you um is
actually from GitHub itself in my slides
I may have linked it to it but Microsoft
maintains an artifact registry uh most
of those things are officially put out
there for the community use but I think
you can see the licensing terms uh the
GitHub ones I believe are part of gith
hubs like just open source like they
buil the images that said Nothing Stops
you creating your own custom Docker
image publishing into that registry and
using that if that's your concern
Microsoft open source this uh the the
this image the universal image yes it's
you have to look at I don't it is a it
is okay it's in the Reg and anyone can
use it it's called Universal but you you
did bring up one remember you asked for
this so you're going to watch this
now I mean
like so the nice thing is you can go in
and see what it has and you can see that
the only thing I'd say is this is your
you know one siiz fit Sol it's
everything right so it kind of gets big
so when I install it for instance it
actually will install pytorch it
installs um a couple of other libraries
I'm trying to think of it's a lot of
stuff because it has hey there's a
machine learning notebook that you can
use you don't need all of that stuff in
reality that's said for people like me I
like to start with this at least in
demos because I can literally build a
notebook and then I can write an app in
node or like the Muse react and it'll
run in the same thing and I'm done but
yeah you can go check this in here and
I'm wondering if they have uh okay here
it says MIT license over there okay but
you can go yeah I mean I mean this is an
atomic this is an atomic this is an
atomic ref presentation of what's needed
to be executed for aign toic computing
platform that's why I was asking the
licensing questions yeah is all these oh
but yeah oh God I like I love people
like this so so actually I also show you
something else go ahead keep going there
is um how do
I is there an
interface um and I'm saying that for the
purposes of East uh for me to connect an
execution Paradigm outside of
container to this container wouldn't run
in this container yes and I don't necess
within the interest of agnosticism uhhuh
because I'm surprised to see an MIT
license
on um so I'm going to split that into
two questions that I heard you ask one
is can you put your own versions of it
somewhere right like can you build your
own custom image is that what you're
asking or can you customize it after
that image has been installed I wouldn't
be executing my processes Within this
container be external yes I was just
wondering if there are utilities to
facilitate the specification of Uris for
such purposes yeah so two things right
one is and I hope I'm getting your
question right one is that you look at
this right I have this post create
command and in here I can actually do
whatever like I'm installing other stuff
after the fact that I want to like work
on and there is a thing I have to do to
like fix some issues that were in there
but I can actually install stuff and
customize what's there so that's one the
second thing is that um I couldn't if I
wanted to start a new container when you
actually start a new container or when
you ask her to start a new container
it's going to give you a whole bunch of
options for things that you can build
you can actually go look at it but since
you ask for the specification that's
right that's what I was thinking about
if you go to container dodev containers
dodev is that what it is so Dev
container is a specification so if you
go into this you can actually go see the
there is examples and reference of how
what it is it's just a specification for
how you define your Docker container
image right so as long as you're using
all open source stuff you can create a
document put if you're using proprietary
stuff you probably want to say hey if
you're going to use this please make
sure that you have the appropriate
licenses the third part is where you run
it if you want to run it in GitHub in
code spaces you can do that but if you
want to run it in a private container
like in a container app in a cloud you
can do that too the the main thing is
that the specification makes it
reproducible so what I really would love
is every time someone makes a demo ship
it with a Dev container Json so that
when I'm tring your
demo I actually have an image that you
built and I think that the value then
I'll show you a different thing but
here's the thing yeah like for any
comprehensive solution like this yes um
the only flavor of limux where you could
put a doctor container inside a doctor
container
that's why I'm asking because I know all
the execution wouldn't Ur in this
container this is just an entry point
yeah but you can customize the docker
images that you Des saw we uh can show
you some examples if you want to come
look at it where we start with that
image that you saw but then we actually
have Docker files that are kind of like
doing other things on top featur okay
I'm cing this yeah you can come I'll
also yeah I'll also show you this
example from the playr team where they
ship an image every time every month
that updates it with the latest thing so
that's the kind of thing I see where you
really building a product you ship
activity would be would be what thank
you yeah the mdle uh feel free to come
chat with me and I thank you